bonjour bonjour on va dit représenter
oui alors moi c'est valentine je suis
vidéaste et journaliste et je tiens la
chaîne si en ce comptoir et qu'est ce
que tu fais de beaux faits tionale elle
pas impossible qu'un jour je le mange
pas mal je me balade squat gens mettent
les gens qui sont sur le stand du café
des sciences et qui ont un super stands
vraiment c'est super faire de la musique
avec des légumes brown qui l'a pourrais
tu me dire qui est en plus vieux
souvenirs de science mais plus vieux
souvenirs de science je crois que c'est
quand je fouille est dans la boîte de
minéraux de mon frère je vous voyez tous
les pays où toutes les couleurs que vous
voyez ça me fascinait et voilà donc
c'est pour ça que j'ai fait des études
de géologie hop et où est-ce qu'on peut
te retrouver sur internet sur le blog la
chaîne youtube